earth
us air
us earth
us but hang on aren't we part of the air
we're organic creatures made of the same
molecules as everything else on our
planet
one interconnected ecosystem that keeps
us all alive but are we superior
different or special why do we
often feel well separate from the earth
in fact not everyone does
throughout human history lots of
cultures have viewed their relationship
to the earth in other ways
many still do animism the belief that
spirit infuses objects nature and the
whole of existence is a fundamental
principle of many indigenous societies
in taoism cosmic energy or life force
is everywhere and is constantly seeking
harmony and balance between
all things ancient andean civilizations
place the spirit of pachamama or mother
earth
at the very centre of their world view
and today for many indigenous people of
the world
like the ua tribe in colombia the earth
is not just the dust from which human
beings are made
it's the spirit of their people and
ancestors it's their
history it is life itself
this isn't always an easy idea for
people in today's western societies to
grasp
the druids of ancient britain did grasp
it
focusing their spiritual practices on a
reverence and connection with nature
but when christianity spread through
europe animism was condemned
as pagan and savage european colonialism
enforced these views around the globe in
places like the americas and australia
crushing the indigenous peoples and
their nature wisdom
since the birth of agriculture humans
had been manipulating the world around
them harnessing
dividing and selling its natural
resources but under colonization the
earth became a place to be
conquered dominated farmed fished
plundered
and mined on a vast scale
was there any scientific thinking behind
our ever
increasing control over the natural
world
seventeenth century europe thought so in
fact
thought was all the rage then as french
philosopher
rene descartes and others like sir isaac
newton
helped to kick off the enlightenment an
era
that prized reasoning science and order
a new view of the world emerged with
human beings
as the thinking rational masters and
nature as our unthinking unfeeling
servant
standing apart from her humans
investigated nature's ultimate questions
dissecting her into smaller and smaller
pieces
this brought us great power and with
great power
comes
you know the rest the anthropocene age
had begun
an epoch defined by one dominant species
us on a planet that is billions of years
old
in just 500 years much of the human race
has come to see itself as the rulers
and center of all life today
we are still trying to bend the planet's
environment processes and biodiversity
to our will
our vast sprawling cities have pushed
nature
out of sight and out of mind the world
is attempting to meet the urgent
challenge of climate change
but can anything fundamentally change
while we still see ourselves as somehow
separate from earth there are signs of
hope
other voices are starting to be heard
once again influenced by a resurgent
indigenous view of pachumama
bolivia and ecuador have passed laws
granting all nature equal rights with
humans
and in new zealand a maori tribe has
successfully fought to have their river
and ancestor given the same legal rights
as a person
in an interconnected world can we humans
find ways to truly reconnect
to all life on the planet a new era
might start with one single idea
there is no earth and us we are one
you